a foundation in France hopes Americans
will donate money to help save one of
the country's most iconic historic
buildings the notre-dame Cathedral in
Paris is home to some of Catholicism's
most important relics they include the
crown of thorns said to have been worn
by Jesus conservationists say the
building is in desperate need of repair
Roxana Saberi got rare access to parts
of the 855 year-old Cathedral that are
starting to deteriorate for 13 million
visitors a year
nutri dom cathedral soars and splendor
no Saddam it's beautiful it has been
worth every minute of my time
but beyond its facade can you tell I
could not tell look closely you'll see
this majestic medieval monument is
falling apart you see a piece of the
pinnacle here and you see two pieces of
the railing Michele Pico is raising
money to keep the cathedral from
crumbling on the roof he showed us walls
chipping stones stapled together and
Gothic gargoyles used to drain rain
replaced with plastic pipes here what we
see is a wooden railing which has been
put to replace the original railing
which was here years of rain snow and
pollution are eroding the flying
buttresses that prop the Cathedral up
therefore there's a risk to the whole
Cathedral it's falling down Church
officials say the cathedral is for now
safe to visit but it has reached a
tipping point we are behind no trudeau
min the backyard these are stones that
have either fallen off the Cathedral or
were at risk of falling off there are
hundreds of them here the hope is to fix
them up and put them back but the
Archdiocese of Paris says it can't
afford all the fixes estimated at one
hundred eighty-five million dollars the
French government which owns the
Cathedral has pledged around 50 million
that leaves a bill of 135 million
dollars to raise the rest
Piko helped launched the Friends of
Notre Dame of Paris foundation it's
working to find private donors in France
and across the Atlantic we know that
Americans are wealthy and so this is
clear that we go where we think we can
find money to help restore the Cathedral
some Americans may ask why should we
help pay to fix your national monument
Notre Dame the puppy is not Paris
monuments or a French monument or a
European Union but it's really old white
monuments the monument last got a major
makeover more than 150 years ago
inspired partly by Victor Hugo's
description of its decaying state in the
hunchback of notre dom
but the Cathedral spokesman says today
the government is overwhelmed with other
monuments that need maintenance and many
French people feel by paying taxes
they're already doing enough to help the
church nobody wants to do this work in
France we need to ask American people to
help us he points out that nutri dom is
a part of American history and to these
Yanks merci merci beaucoup the French
and US troops celebrated there after
liberating Paris from Germany in World
War two and for many Americans it's been
a top tourist destination I love it
that's me I'm a history person it's
really beautiful
I like the stained glass windows and all
the beautiful colors in the history to
it entry for everyone is free hey Amy
yes Monsignor Patrick survey why he
couldn't raise money for repairs by
charging a fee couldn't somebody because
we are not in a museum he said we are in
an active living Church this is a place
of grace
it now depends on the good grace of
others to survive for CBS this morning
Roxana Saberi Paris
what a beautiful shot